hey guys welcome to the latest way you
can lose all your money today we're
talking about the three-step system to
how he makes thirty thousand dollars a
month and completely passive income by
simply uploading 25-page Word documents
to Amazon this very reminiscent of the
tiny classified ads which placing tiny
classified ads in the newspaper this
program is by Ty Cohen and pushed by
anique single and they have they have a
little intro that I think tells you
everything you need to know on average
what I found is between myself my
students right and he's the students
that are across the planet thousands of
students to connect their result results
each ebook write each word doc generates
about five hundred dollars a month
Amazon takes care of everything this is
in your pocket five hundred dollars
we're going to need I'd say about 15
books on average right to get to about a
hundred thousand a year all you need is
25 page word documents on Amazon in
today's competitive market thanks to
these clowns okay so what do we find out
they're talking about publishing on
Kindle they're talking about doing what
Steph and James did with his books like
you have the alcoholism cure by Stephan
Hall which is a pin name doesn't really
exist
Tyko and basically want you to do the
same thing but with 15 books and he says
each of them should net you about five
hundred dollars a month I want to show
you that they really are pushing how
quote easy this program is I want you
guys to see this I could come up with
about fifteen topics in 30 minutes or so
maybe Wow and that's that's the Giffen a
curse because it becomes really
addictive
doing this yeah but I mean not to
oversimplify but that means you're
sitting you know you're thirty minutes
away from $100,000 a year salary
absolutely wow I've never seen such a
clear-cut example of someone trying to
sell a get-rich-quick scheme let's
listen that again no means you're
sitting you know you're thirty minutes
away from a hundred thousand dollar a
year salary absolutely but that means
you're sitting you know you're thirty
minutes away from $100,000 years
absolutely and so I feel it's great is
the thing the people that get how simple
this is and actually act the suckers who
believe this stuff we love them if you
believe me when I say you can make 100
grand
using in 30 minutes by coming up with 15
book topics to create 25 page word Docs
and upload them to Amazon if you get
that if you believe that you're perfect
you're perfect for us Jay you're just
who we're looking for man so check out
these comments - I mean just because
y'all never think that anyone Falls for
this stuff I can finally monetize my two
greatest passions thanks a lot
ty and an eek from this part 1 video
this series they definitely came to my
decision then Japan Scott I'm excited
and looking forward to the training ISTA
I'm excited lord knows I've been waiting
for this guys if you don't believe
anybody's falling for this stuff you're
crazy
now here's the thing they're pitching
this as a free training right but really
this is an upsell this is an upsell to
Kindle cash flow which is Ty's course is
697 that's that's what they're actually
selling you on ok now here's where the
drama sort of sets in because all right
so we have this Kindle cash flow they're
both promoting this thing but you might
be wondering well did they show any
evidence that they actually made a ton
of money doing this thing well yes
somebody did they posted this screenshot
right here which shows that they made
over $200,000 with Kindle books one of
the coaches in the course says it says
this but then I was approached by the
guy whose numbers those actually are
because those are stolen numbers that's
a stolen screenshot that was put on to
Ty scores here's Ty's course
here's Kindle cash flows page where
they're trying to sell you on this
program right they're trying to sell you
on the idea that all you need to do
you're 30 minutes away from $100,000 a
year but they stole somebody else's
numbers so this is Bobby Kim he is a
Kindle guru I do not support his course
I do not endorse this course I don't I
think you're an idiot if you buy an
online paid course you guys know how I
feel about that I told him I would be
saying that but he wanted to come on
anyways and explain how his
his numbers got ripped off and why
that's upsetting and why this kind of
program will never work to emphasize
they don't mention that you spent how
much in ads to get those 250k late like
a hundred grand at least it was more
than underground like at least maybe 120
130 over like the six months which is a
lot of money I mean it is a lot of money
to touch any each way into those profits
that he started with but then the way
Tyco and handled it is my favorite thing
ever okay
this is my great this is this is my
favorite thing of all time so you send
him a message
hey tied these are my numbers now Josh
for Marty's I spoke to them please take
them down they didn't do a quarter of a
million in six months those are from my
account that I posted in my mastermind
group
I also saw this as well you guys are
selling your programs using my numbers
and being vague about this as well to
potential customers please take them
down immediately thank you and at which
point at which point Ty's response
should be nothing less then absolutely
I'm so sorry this happened I don't know
how this happened this is impossible
because I would never steal I would
never steal numbers right all right go
ahead so then I send him a loom and I'm
like dude like can you take him down I
told I tell the coaches because ty
wasn't responding I'm like dude like
because just Josh was like oh like you
know like ty isn't involved like this is
my fault I'm like dude like all I want
ty is to send me an apology because it's
why also bash me on social media like
but but anyway this is what he sends me
8 o'clock in the morning on Sunday hey
fat boy you want an apology I'm sorry
that I won't beat your fat ass or make
you suck my chubby go ahead and marketer
there's your apology you just a no
little boy you really started some [ __ ]
so you [ __ ] your lawyer your mother for
having you yeah so I said lo lo que like
ty you're the biggest thought on earth
he's like your father for not all of
your face or making her swallow your
dumb ass get your lawyer on that and
then we'll talk about this in person
when I see you because I will see you
and then we can talk and I'm just like
Oh
yeah and then he's like I think he
deleted of messages I know he said like
something about prison I'm like lol why
would I go to prison when you stole my
numbers to promote your shitty chorus
he's like go post and share all of that
internet gangster and I'm like I sure
will
I don't need fake numbers promote or
sell anything good luck to you as well
um this is amazing no okay and then what
happens is I post that conversation on
Facebook and then this is what he says
let me let me pull it up this was like
the funniest [ __ ] ever so I post that
exact conversation of us on Facebook
right and this is what he says this is
what he says he says so I'm just
catching up all on this it looks like
you're desperate and really good at
photoshopping feet conversations we'll
see how this all holds up I have never
heard of you before so how could I reach
out to someone that has never hit my
radar don't answer because I won't be
responding then I just I just post the
video of our conversation and I'm like
must be some real good Photoshop you
know that was some meltdown stuff dude
that was some million down dude that was
a very professional and courteous but
it's just like these clowns so here's
the thing so these coaches right so I
sent you those screenshots to with Josh
and Marty what I've been really thinking
is I think they probably hustled ty
because I think they maybe showed my
numbers and was like hey we have this
program and we're wondering gonna
partner up you know I think that's what
actually happened I can't say that for
sure but that's just what seems like it
would happen right and I'm like dude
like his name's on the actual program
and on the sales page but is they take
accountability for if you're let's give
a lesson hold on I'm sorry Bobby
hold on let me give it a lesson to the
people okay I understand this these guys
who have to take other people's
screenshots
guess who's making Bank on this course
why don't you run them through a quick
numbers you know rough numbers of how
much they made on this course where
they're not actually doing what they say
for you to do okay runs all the numbers
oh they have like eight so it literally
in the last like five months or six
months since them learn started
promoting them they have about 5,000
people who bought their program at six
ninety seven in the last six I would say
in the last six tonight okay okay so
let's uh let's do the numbers guys gonna
share a little calendar with you guys
all right here's what we're gonna do
697 the
to the course times about 5,000 people
yeah 5,000 cheese and that's not
including upsells as well as their
monthly they have some certain writers
that's how you make money on Kindle baby
you don't make me you don't write books
you sell the cars and get three mil dude
that's in sand dude
hey guys before we get to the last part
of this video and sorry for the lack of
continuity it's cold in here
I wanted to say one thing real quick you
might be asking yourself well why is it
so hard why is it ridiculous that the
same tactics that Stefan James used back
in 2012 and 2013 to you know promote all
these ridiculous pamphlets why is why
won't that work today I'm gonna break
down the whole Amazon Kindle blackhat
publishing thing another time but for
the time being Bobby does a great job of
breaking it down it all has to do with
Kindle unlimited changing their policies
and here you go
so back in 2015 2016 like you were able
to pull this [ __ ] off because again if
you want to get at 5,000 word book 5000
work so on average every 250 words is
about a page on Amazon right so for a
short 20 25 page book you're looking
five maybe seven thousand words right on
average and I know this stuff because I
actually used to go straight for people
and they ask me he's kind of hooks right
the thing is back in the first Kindle
unlimited program you got paid two
dollars and seven cents roughly if they
read the first 10% of your book and if
you have a 25 page book you only have to
read three pages and you make $2 right
and to produce these short books you can
get a shitty cover for like 5 10 but
doesn't matter you know cuz you just
have to get someone to flip through the
first three pages I get a shitty book
cover it cost you maybe like a dollar
for every hundred words so for five for
five thousand words I think about okay
you know how you have to do minimal
proofing minimal editing because it's
really short you can even do it yourself
spellcheck it right like all in maybe 60
bucks right so it's 60 bucks to roll out
they only have to flip through the first
three pages the issue is in 2017 the
whole program changed okay because
Amazon caught on because you know think
about this okay if you're
your Amazon and I'm paying you $9.99 a
month to read all the books in your
program but you still have to pay me $2
for every 10% right like minimum 10% oh
yeah they'll lose money yeah exactly
like you have I'd probably be reading 30
or 50 of these every single month you're
losing like a hundred bucks plus so what
happened was Amazon ten Amazon switched
this and this is the funny [ __ ] ever
like 95% of these people or even more
who doing short books they lost your
whole business these are already paying
you it's roughly like half a cent per
page so that means all these short books
are only gonna make someone like like 10
cents now all right they're not gonna
make them $2 anymore they'll make it ten
cents so that's when the game started to
change but guys like if anyone tells you
anything guys like and this is from
someone who actually like you know like
is in the guru world you know just tell
you guys look if there are people out
there saying this is how you make easy
money that you can do this with minimal
work you just push a button and make
money guys like you're just like
tricking yourself okay like they're just
telling you what you want to hear
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]